τι ποια είναι ενημέρωση που έχουμε τώρα σε πιές χώρες τηετα προβλήματα που έχουμε ενελείψεις
αύριο το πρωί θα ήθελα να μας πεις κάποιος ις ηγήσεις για να βρούμε λύσεις
κάθε μέρα για τρεις μήνες αφυπήρχαν στιγμέ που φοβηηθείκατε υπήρχε και ένα κίμα οργής από
κάπους στο άκουσμα των εμβολίων το άκουσμα των μέτρων πύρξαν και κάποιες ακρές καταστάεις ακόμε
και έδω στην χώρα μας υπήρχαν στιγμές που ιστέλνα κυριακίδου φοβήθηκε για όλα αυτά όχι
ποτέ δεφοβήθηκα ποτέ δεν εσθάνθηκα ότι δεν θα πετύχουμε ύξερω ότητα δύσκολο καταλαβαίνω και καταλάβαι
να την οργεί και την αγανάκτηση καταλάβαινα το τησημαίνει να είσαι περιορισμένο σπίτη σου τοακλείσει
στην επιχείρηση σου των α υπηρειάζεταιη οικονομία αυτό έκαμε ακόμη πιο επιτακτικό το να βρούμε
λύσεις λ επίσης αυτό που κατάλαβα από την αρχί και ίσως μετά των πρώ τους
δυοτρεις δύο μήνες θα έλεγα και οι πόλη πς χώρες το συντοποιήσαν είν ότι δεν
υπήρχεν τρόπος να ξεπεράσουμε αυτή την κρίση δεν υπήρχε συνεργασία αναμεταξύ των κσιεφτά οι αρχικές
προσπάθειες ι κάθε χώρα να κινήθειαν μόνη της να κλήσει σύν ώρα ένα ιώς δεν
περιορίζεται εντότο συνόρον έπρεπε όλοη μαζί και μόλις αυτή η αλληλεγκή δημιουργήθηκε και οι συνεργασία
και έγινε με την καθημερινή επο αφήμε τους υπουργού σηγείας όλον των κρατομελών ήμουν θα
έλεγα πολύ πιο ήσυχη ότι στο τέλος θα τα καταφέρναμε μπήκαν ι βάσεις βαλάτα και
συ τις βάσις αυτά πέντε χρόνια είναι την είναι έτοιμος ο κόσμος για ακόμη μια
πανδημία το πομένο διάστημα μετά πό τα μαθύματα από πο